موسم الرياض ينطلق بنزال اشرس رجل على وجه
الارض والجدل مستمر في العالم العربي بين
استمرار الفعاليات الفنيه او الغائها
تضامنا مع ضحايا غزه ومحمد رمضان يتحدى
القناه العاشره الاسرائيليه اليكم الابرز
في
[موسيقى]
اسبوع بينما اجلت او الغيت العديد من
الفعاليات الفنيه في العالم العربي تعاطفا
مع الضحايا المدنيين في غزه بقيت اجنده
السعوديه الثقافيه والترفيهيه ثابته على
مواعيدها اهلا وسهلا بكم في موسم
الرياض وانطلقت النسخه الرابعه من موسم
الرياض الاحد بمواجهه وصفت بالتاريخ لنزال
اشرس رجل على وجه الارض بين فرانسيس
انجانه وتايسون فيوري على حزام الموسم
الذي فاز فيه بطل المجلس العالمي للملاكمه
في الوزن الثقيل فيوري وسبق النزال حفل
شارك فيه مغنون عالميون وحفل جالا دينر في
اليوم الذي سبقه حضره نخبه من ابطال
الملاكمه ونجوم الفن والرياضه في
العالم وتاتي انطلاقه موسم الرياض بنسخته
الرابعه في السعوديه وسط الجدل الذي ساد
مؤخرا على منصات التواصل بين اصحاب وجهه
النظر التي تؤكد على ضروره تاجيل
الفعاليات الثقافيه والفنيه خلال هذه
الفتره تعاطفا مع الضحايا المدنيين في غزه
ومن يرون بان هذه الفعاليات يجب ان تستمر
باعتبارها مصدر الرزق القائمين على هذه
الصناعه مع التاكيد على التعاطف الكامل
وبعض الفنانين اختار الاستمرار في تقديم
حفلاته والتبرع بريع لدعم عائلات الضحايا
وجهود
الاغاثه كنت على امل ان الموسم مثلا يتلغي
يتاجل زي مثلا ما حصل في مهرجان الجون هنا
ومهرجان
القاهره او يحصل
ان الموضوع يهدى هناك في فلسطين غزه
وتصاعد هذا الجدل مع اعلان الفنان المصري
محمد سلام في فيديو نشره عبر حسابه الرسمي
على انستغرام انسحابه من المشاركه في
العرض المسرحي زواج اصطناعي المقرر تقديمه
في موسم الرياض وذلك قبل موعد سفره الى
العاصمه السعوديه بيوم واتى رد رئيس هيئه
الترفيه في المملكه تركي ال الشيخ شديد
اللهجه على من وصفهم بالمزاد الذين
يستخدمون اسم المملكه او اسمه او اسم موسم
الرياض كشما لتحويل ظار عن حدث اخر او وضع
اخر وتم استبدال الفنان المصري محمد انور
بزميله سلام وحرص ال الشيخ على زياره
بروفات العرض الذي سينطلق في
موعده وفي جدل مرتبط بردود افعال الفنانين
على ما يجري في غزه زعم الفنان المصري
محمد رمضان في فيديو نشره عبر حسابه
الرسمي على انستغرام ان القناه العاشره
الاسرائيليه تطالب الشعب الاسرائيلي
بمقاطعه اعماله بسبب الفيديو السابق الذي
نشره وقال قال انه حث فيه العرب على
الاتحاد من اجل اهل غزه ورد بان ذلك اقل
واجب يفعله تجاه اخوته على حد وصفه وكشف
بنبره متحديه ان اسم شخصيته في مسلسله
المقبل ستكون ابو عبيده في اشاره الى اسم
الناطق العسكري باسم كتائب القسام اسم
شخصيتي في المسلسل القادم ان شاء الله ابو
عبيده وبعيدا عن الاجواء العنيفه في
المنطقه ساد الحزن حول العالم بين محبي
المم الامريكي ماثو بيري نجم السلسله
الكوميديه الامريكيه الشهيره فرينز الذي
فارق الحياه بطريقه ماساويه في حادث غرق
بمنزله عن عمر
عاما